[music]
I heard you calling on the megaphone.
You want to see me all alone.
[music] As legend has it, you are quite
the pyro. You light the [music] match to
watch it blow. And if you'd never come
for me, I might have drowned in the
melon [singing]
[music] calling. I swore my loyalty to
me, myself and I. Right before you lit
my [singing and music] sky,
all that [music] time I sat alone in my
tower. You were just haunting your
powers. Now I [music] can see it all.
One night you took me out of my grave
and saved my heart from the fate of
feeling [music]
100 on the land through the sky. Put
your lead just to your hands, your team,
your vibes. [music] I care where the
hell you been out. It's got to be the
sleepless night [music] you've been
dreaming of.
Oh, Oilia,
the [music] eldest daughter of a
nobleman. [singing]
Oily lived [music] in fantasy.
The love was a cold bed full
[music and singing] of scorpions. The
venom stole her sanity.
[music] And if you'd never call me, I
might have lingered in purgatory.
[music]
You wrap around me like a chasing a
crown of fire [music]
pulling me into [singing] the fire.
All that time [music] alone in my tower.
You were just haunting your powers. Now
I can see it all. [music]
One night me out of my grave. Save my
heart from the fo [music]
100 on the land. See [music] the sky.
Your alleges to your hands, your team,
your vibes. you. Where the hell you
been? [music]
Your mind. It's about to be the
sleepless night you've been dreaming of.
Oh,
is locked inside my memory and only
[music] you possess the key. No longer
drowning and deceived. All because you
came for me. Locked inside [music] my
memory and only you possess the key. No
longer drowning and deceived. All
because [music] you came [singing] for
me.
All that time alone in my toe. You were
[music] just haunting your powers. Now I
can see it all. Can see it all.
You took me out of my grave. Save my
heart from the fle [music and singing]
[music]
where the hell you been. Now it's about
to be the sleepless night you've been
dreaming of [music] the fate. Oh,
you saved my heart from the fate of
feel. [sighs]
[music]
>> [music]
>> Hey friends, I hope you enjoyed that
flow session as much as I enjoyed
performing it. That was down at the
Yards Park here in DC and it is one of
my favorite locations in this city.
>> [snorts]
>> If you enjoyed uh checking out those Orb
Poi Pros, that is the LED contact po
that I was using in this video, you can
actually get 10% off on them when you
use the promo code Drexfactor with a
zero instead of an O at checkout over at
ultrao.com. Once again, that is
drexfactor with a zero instead of an O.
Thank you so much to Ultraoy for
sponsoring this video and giving me a
reason to get out and explore my flow in
DC. Speaking of thank yous, I owe thanks
to the friends of the channel. Big
thanks to Dark Monk, Firemecca,
Flowfests, Flow Toys, Pyroer, Light
Toys, and Ultraoy for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible. You
can learn more about all these amazing
companies and the work they're doing to
support Flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that I've got
down in the description of this video.
And finally, this video and all the
videos on this channel would not exist
if it were not for my amazing supporters
on Patreon. In particular, I'd love to
give a huge shout out to my FL patrons
who are listed on screen right now.
Thank you. You all rock. And if you out
there watching want to get your name in
the credits or access to a host of other
awesome rewards, you can do so by
heading on over to my Patreon at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo
and signing up. I'll include a link to
it down in the description as well as up
in the cards. Thank you so much for
watching this video. If you'd like to
check out more of my flow sessions, I
will go ahead and include a link to a
playlist to those videos down in the
description as well as up on screen.
Please make sure to get out and flow
yourselves today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon. Take care now.
Peace.